maintenant il va pleurer à lesmo
cannabis on y va on va tirer sur vous
et regardez juste en face de
ses studios du débat de ce soir et
quitte la ligue quel nom le petit
forestier al aqsa a été tiré au sort 110
forestier up car régie des satellites
carrément des paraboles la même que mon
père il avait pour capter m6 à l'époque
on a mis la parabole est là et là je
sais pas ce que je sais pas s'ils ont
prévu un défilé je sais pas pour
balenciaga mais il ya un immense podium
là et vont arriver là voilà c'est mais
coulisses en live priorité au direct bfm
ce qu'ils font menacer gay quand tu es
en pleine nature c'est de l'eau peut
sans problème parce que si il fait beau
dehors
c'est la mauricie
ma chérie tu as ta voiture tu vas faire
défoncer j'ai fait un accès en voiture
j'ai heurté la voiture d'un mec ans en
afrique propriété sur l'auto patrouille
maintenant je m'apprête à draguer en
disant que c'est un signe du destin que
falcon se rencontrent je fais du boeuf à
jeudi qu'il avait raison je suis parti
chercher une bouteille de champagne pour
célébrer notre rencontre que j'avais pas
encore et puis je vais donner lui lui
oui il a dû la moitié narbonnais votre
boulot j'ai attendu que la police arrive
caen et rennes fait
faut-il impérativement sa carte
d'électeur pour aller voter et bien non
ce n'est pas obligatoire mais si vous ne
l'avez pas sur vous il vous faudra tout
de même une carte d'identité l'enjeu
c'est évidemment de vérifier que vous
êtes bien inscrits sur les listes
électorales et que c'est bien vous qui
êtes là ce jour là et pas quelqu'un
d'autre qui chercheraient à voter à
votre place